ap ap ap
françois g j'ai une lettre pour toi
lettres quoi rentrer ça monsieur
françois l'île aux enfants guy ritchie
mode qu mollira ce qu'il ya dedans en
body dont aussi c'est pas trop personnel
voyons cher françois
pourrais tu nous raconter un jour
pourquoi l'île d'er casimir est devenue
l'île aux enfants signé olivier c'est
une bonne idée ça dit dont casino
j'ai compris j'ai compris je vais vite
me préparer lors d'une dépêche
les enfants les enfants venaient voir
rené année venez installez vous tient
rythme-là 40 aller voilà je vais vous
raconter comment l'île d'er casimir est
devenue l'île aux enfants
c'était au 16e siècle il ya 400 ans
c'est l'époque des grands explorateurs
les conquistadors souvenait de
christophe colomb de magellan de cortez
et puis bien d'autres
ces explorateurs cherchait des terres
nouvelles et c'était très cruel très
féroce un jour un navire jette l'ancré
devant l'île d'er casimir us et des
chaloupes sont mises à la mer et sa
proche de la plage
manque de chance c'était les soldats les
plus féroces qui existait à cette époque
là les casimir us les regards d'approché
avec inquiétude
il avait encore jamais vu des hommes
alors vous pensez bien il se méfie et
heureusement qui se méfie parce que les
soldats attrape les animaux qui se
trouve à portée de leurs mains et
commence par les tuer ils tirent des
coups de feu avec des espèces d'engins
qu'on appelle des arcs buzaului ça
marchait pas toujours très bien
quelquefois ça leur exploser la figure
mantin les kazimierz n'avais jamais
entendu deux coups de feu et ça leur a
fait peur à cette époque le règne des
casimir us n'avaient jamais cessé depuis
des milliers et des milliers d'années
est-ce que vous souvenez de casimir us
premier le roi qui avait chassé de lille
les féroces tyrannosaurus qui s'y
trouvaient je vous l'avais raconter une
fois en souvenez eh bien depuis des
milliers d'années les rois s'étaient
succédé et un petit ennui
c'est que les quais mais il unit russe
était très très mauvais en calcul il
mélangeait tous les numéros des rois ne
savais pas si c'était le roi actuel
casimir us 931 quasi virus 7849 ou
casimir us 535 ennemis 535 ennemis
anomalies qu'on n'a jamais pu expliquer
alors le roi de l'époque qui connaissait
par son numéro était très vexé et un
jour il dit puisque c'est comme ça [ __ ]
dit qu il ya plus droit et c'est à cette
époque à peu près que les soldats sont
taries 7849 ou casimir us 535 ennemis
535 ennemis anomalies qu'on n'a jamais
pu expliquer alors le roi de l'époque
qui connaissait par son numéro et
trawick c est un jour il dit puisque
c'est comme ça [ __ ] dit qu il ya plus de
roi et c'est à cette époque à peu près
que les soldats sont arrivés dans l'île
donc à cette époque les casimir russes
vivent sans roi et entre nous il s'en
porte pas plus mal pour ça alors les
animaux affolé vont voir les casimir us
dans les bois et leur disent écoutez les
kanji virus vous êtes les plus grands
vous êtes les plus forts il faut nous
aider faut faire quelque chose
les casser miros réfléchissent et ça y
est j'y trouve une idée qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on va se déguiser en monstre
pour faire peur aux envahisseurs d'une
bonne idée nos et vous savez ce que ça a
donné à peu près je vous le montrez moi
casimir allez viens casimir voilà nous
montrer sa voie là
alors stop stop casimir on a compris
alors évidemment quand les soldats ont
vu les casimir us déguisés comme ça ils
ont eu une panique terrible il fuyait
dans tous les sens à droite à gauche
il criait pousser des hurlements de
frayeur on les entendait dans toute
l'île et à toute vitesse
hop il regagne la plage qui sautent dans
leur chaloupe il n'y a pas assez de
place pour tout le monde
ils se bagarrent il y en a qui rentra à
la nage tout le monde regagne le navire
on lève l'ancré hop le bateau s'éloigne
à l'horizon alors vous imaginez bien
qu'en voyant partir toute cette équipe
et les qassimi russes ont poussé un ouf
de soulagement
ils étaient très contents mais aussi
c'était très étonné pourquoi et bien sûr
le rivage il restait deux petits soldats
en réalité c'est des deux petits mousses
qui étaient restées là on les avait
oubliés dans les casinos et russes
disent mais il reste deux il faut les
chasser
allons-y ils arrivent ils font les
grands gestes pour leur faire peur tu es
très très très gros geste mais plus gras
comme casimir fait et plus les casimir
us faisait des grands gestes pour faire
peur aux petits mousses plus les petits
mousses rigoler ah ouais je me souviens
très bien mon grand père m'a raconté que
c'est alors ils faisaient comme ça waouh
et voilà et plus les casimir us
s'exciter en faisant des grands gestes
plus les petits mousses triais alors le
plus grand des casimir us guy attendez
je vais régler ça il s'approche tout
seul vers les petits mousses en faisant
des grands gestes
mais les petits mousses s'approche de
lui et commence à le caresser
il caresse et lui dise où tu es gentil
toi t'es gentil qui est très gentil
casimir usq très très surpris
il avait encore jamais entendu parler le
langage des hommes l'arrêt répond gentil
gentil casimir us se met à sourire aussi
les petits mousses met à rire encore
plus fort elle casimir us rigole aussi à
son tour headline copains et dynamique
alors en leur honneur
les casimir us organise un merveilleux
festin on apporte le plat national des
casimir us à table et qu'est ce que
c'était c'était le globish service que
cette le gloubi
10 c'est un mélange de confiture de
fraises de bananes écrasées et chocolat
en tout bien remuer et casimir us on est
tellement fou n'est ce pas messieurs
extraordinaire oui les petits mousses
woodside tout ça très beau mais pour
remercier disent on va vous donner
quelque chose et casimir us il fouille
dans leur musette et le capitaine leur
avait donné pour leur déjeuner des
saucisses de toulouse et de la moutarde
il les offre aux casimir us les casinos
spectacle qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc là qu'est ce que ça ça n'a pas
l'air très bon on va le mélange est dans
notre globi il le met dans le groupe i à
bien tous meilleurs j'ai eu le tout yg
gouttes et sousse à traiter les appels
zass le le gloubi boulga et ça devient
leur place avant et mais c'est
d'ailleurs toujours le mien 1 le
gloubiboulga gens mangent à radio globo
bourgat adjoint dans les amas très très
bien mais quelques jours plus tard les
navires de guerre reviennent en
direction de l'île d'er qassimi russe
les barques sont mises à l'eau et les
soldats débarquent sur la plage avec en
tête le général le général voit les deux
petits mousses et leur dit venez venez
je viens vous sauver je viens vous
protéger et tous les monstres là je vais
les tuer et les petits mousses qui
disent même et pourquoi pas du tout ce
sont nos amis ils sont très très gentil
puis d'ailleurs nous on veut rester ici
on veut rester avec lesquels zini russe
bondil général mais est-ce que je peux
quand même faire quelque chose qu'on
vous alors les petits mousses qui lie si
vous avez à bord de la saucisse de
toulouse et de la moutarde vous nous les
apportez bien dit le général
voilà et au moment de repartir on entend
une petite voix qui crient parmi
l'équipage et moi est-ce que je peux
rester aussi et les mots stylisme
évidemment que tu peux rester ici c'est
fait pour tous les enfants tous les
enfants sont les bienvenus
lordon tous les bateaux qui étaient là
il y avait pas mal d'enfants de petits
mousses sont tous restés sur l'île avec
les casimir us
les soldats regagnent leur chaloupe et
le général au moment de partir surtout
on est dire mais dites moi a dit moi
cette île là comment l'appeler vous
alors tous en coeur de la plage les
casimir us et les enfants ils ont
répondu c'est l'île aux enfants
les spas casimir
et depuis ce jour là il s'appelle
comment l'île aux enfants
voilà
[Musique]